hi my name is ELISA Anna my question is
how likely is it that there's life out
there
hi Ellis yeah how likely is there to be
life out there in the universe it's a
great question we've many people would
love the discover life especially
intelligent life out there in the
universe I think more scientists now
believe that the chances of finding life
someplace in our galaxy are pretty high
we understand from biology that life
began on earth almost as soon as it
could didn't take long after the earth
quieted down for life to emerge and we
have discovered in recent years that
there are many many planetary systems
revolving around other stars in our
galaxy we have directly observed now
hundreds of what are called exoplanets
planets outside our solar system so
we're learning more and more about
planetary systems around other stars
given that and given that the sum of
those planets seemed to be populating
what astronomers call that habitable
zone the zone in which the planet would
be at the right distance from their Sun
to be warm enough for water to melt and
not hot enough to boil off all the water
in the atmosphere it's very likely that
there are literally millions of planets
revolving around stars in our galaxy
remember there are 10 billion stars in
our galaxy which could support life now
or at some point in their history and we
see no barrier to once the conditions
are right
for life not to emerge we don't exactly
understand how life did evolve at the
very beginnings of life but we're we're
pretty
no one knows any reason why it would be
a very rare occurrence except for the
fact that we haven't observed life
elsewhere to observe life that is not
trying to communicate with us however
what is so far until recently has been
very difficult we can't see planets
except indirectly and and therefore we
can't look to see whether there are any
signs of life on any planet that's not
in our solar system life doesn't that
seem to exist on Mars or Venus or
anywhere else in our solar system as far
as we can tell but there are chances
that within the century we will our
tools will be good enough to detect the
products of life the biochemical
products of life on other planets in
their atmospheres and to conclude
whether or not some form of life does
exist on planets outside our solar
system whether we will be able to
communicate directly with intelligent
technologically advanced forms of life
throughout the galaxy depends on many
unknowns we don't have any much evidence
that intelligent life can survive for
long and given some of our recent
behavior on our earth one might conclude
that intelligent technologically evolved
civilizations are doomed to rapid
extinction which might explain why we
haven't found such signals coming from
extraterrestrial civilizations but
through true answers we don't know it's
one of the most exciting questions that
astronomers and biologists are pursuing
and we'll know a lot more during the
rest of your life